you don't like selfies you don't like  the new Sophie crazy well I don't know  why they call them selfies you know I  get it with a guy like me who's a model  you know I get it but selfies should  they really be called screw use screw  use why well think of it right you got  your phone out you're like hey look at  me I'm at the zoo with a little baby  fluffy lion cub you're not click screw  you yeah the message no I'm scared of  the Alps with my rich friends where  you're in a little cubicle at work that  smells like Campbell's cream of mushroom  [Laughter]  [Applause]  now I'm on the Great Wall of China with  Jon Bon Jovi when somehow he still had  his long hair click you just described I  don't believe the Jon Bon Jovi part  you